so today we're gonna talk about
something that I really really like it's
a combination of two things I really
like actually serverless functions and
view jeaious so how many of you can
predict the future
are there any Bitcoin millionaires in
the house or early Apple investors maybe
you wouldn't be here if you were alright
I'm not either so I don't know how to
predict the future when you launch an
app for the rest of us what does that
look like well after you're done jumping
around in formalwear all over a skyline
and you're super excited then you
immediately have to scale your servers
and I think that we'd all like to feel
like we probably look like this when
we're doing that we're likely trackers
with like a dark hoodie on and I were so
good at programming that our fingers are
literally on fire but we probably look
more like this that dough puddi is like
our sisters hand-me-down rain jacket and
we can't find the Q key and even if we
do we're not sure if we can exit them so
what about the situation where we don't
exactly fail but we don't really succeed
either we just don't get as many signups
out of the gate as we really want it to
and in that situation we can scale down
but what if things kick up again down
the road and then we're paying for all
this server capacity that we're not
actually using John Travolta's shows up
in our wallet which is really awkward to
explain to VP's you know so that brings
us to serverless serverless is an
actually interesting thing with a really
quick Beatty title I mean it's true
anytime you talk about several it's the
first thing anyone is ever gonna tell
you is like well you're actually still
using servers that's true we are still
actually using servers so why are we
calling it that well the idea of server
list is that you spend less time setting
up and maintaining a server you're not
spending as much time babysitting a
server so basically all of the things
that you're kind of working on for
infrastructure are abstracted away from
you so the promise of server lists is
really focusing on functions that state
when this request comes in run this code
and for that reason a lot of people call
it fast
or functions as a service my name is
Sarah Dresner as mentioned before I'm
Sarah IDO on Twitter I work for
Microsoft then and I'm also a via Cordy
member I work for CSS tricks as a staff
writer there and I'm here today to talk
to you about serverless functions and
view so some of the benefits include
that you're only paying for what you use
which is usually a lot less and here's a
really special thing about server lists
basically they priced it way too low
right out of the gate and then everyone
had to compete at this like really low
cost so everyone's competing and not
making money which means that that's
really good for a consumer like me
because I'm not paying for it basically
it's just been really inappropriately
priced so you're paying a lot less to do
stuff so even if you want to check
things out and try things out you can do
so without a lot of risk you spend less
time babysitting a server we talked
about that a little bit before and it's
the same idea as functional programming
we're really boiling things down into
smaller reusable functions and I really
like that premise and another premise I
really like is the principle of least
power which in programming basically
means that you use the least powerful
programming principle in order to get
things done and that kind of simplicity
can help you reuse things and it can
help keep things simple and it can help
reduce failures so we mentioned before
that server lists can mean functions as
a service and there's a lot of as a
service kind of things out there so I
made this SVG animation so you can kind
of compare some of them so let's take a
look so here is infrastructure as a
service you can see you're managing
everything above that water line
platform as a service a little bit less
and functions as a service you're just
maintaining that application that's
pretty powerful you're not dealing with
any of the infrastructure so now when we
usually deploy server-side software we
start with a host instance then we
deploy the application within the host
in a server list paradigm we remove both
and replace it with a vendor fast
platform that we're not actually
managing ourselves so we'll deploy these
flunk'd functions within this platform
and this allows us to instead focus on
the logic which are written as
individual functions so unlike that
earlier host and application model the
function isn't continuously running when
an event is triggered then the function
is executed by the vendor inside of a
container so you might be familiar with
this sticker right but there is no cloud
it's just someone else's computer
well there's no server list it's just
someone else's fully managed execution
environment that I only pay a fraction
of cent for whenever my function is run
got it great
so does this mean we should serverless
all the things sounds great
um no not really
serverless is really good for a few use
cases some of which we're gonna cover
today but it's not good for a
long-running stuff nothing with a
persistent connection like WebSockets so
a real-time social updating stream so
chatting or if you're you know doing a
game where people can are continuously
talking to each other or any kind of
like stock ticker or something like that
where you're maintaining that connection
all the time that's not really a good
case for surveillance so ever this is
really good for functions that you want
to execute directly off of a server so
what is it good for we're gonna talk
about some of these today we're gonna
clean data on a cron job take data and
music to create data visualizations we
can crop images uploaded by the user and
create a user profile we can also do
things like create a server list API
very very easily which we're gonna do
today as well so I'm as I mentioned
before I work for Microsoft so some of
the examples that I'm going to show
today use asher but you can totally make
use of all of these things in any kind
of service as well and I'll even show
you the line of code that you would
change all of these examples are open
source and available on my github so you
can also just grab them play with them
really quickly and throw them away or
what have you so ok so setting up a
function is pretty trivial we'll go get
a free account and then we go into the
portal and we have a number of options
that mostly get populated for us so one
of the things that I want to point out
here is this this is my first time using
keynote but I promise I don't do
transitions like that all the
but I really liked it so this is the
consumption plan that's the one that you
want to use the other option is app
service plan consumption plan is the one
that's going to scale along with your
needs the app service plan you're gonna
have to do things a little bit more
manually so right away they'll setup us
up with a test which I kind of
simplified and modified to include tacos
I apologize the text is a little bit
small here but the request body I'm
passing in a name per am that says
delicious tacos tacos are very important
for everybody to know about here we've
got this context Reza and in that body
we're passing in the reck body name so
we're passing in that parameter there
and you can see that context log very
similar to a console.log and so if we
run this we can see that we're passing
this in and down here we have this
output on the corner here hello
delicious tacos and you can also see
that yoyoyoyoyo is printed into the
context log so there wasn't that much
stuff to get things going you can see
how you pass in parameters you can see
how that the function is executed and
you can see how we'd manage that output
and even log so that brings us to view
stripe and server lists so the first
thing we're gonna go over three examples
today the first one is setting up an
e-commerce site and we're gonna set up
an e-commerce site all the way through
payment completion in just a few minutes
so this is really super exciting so
let's put the knowledge to good use
here's a sample view shop that I made
and basically you can order things you
can't really because it's a sample oh
but this whole you know application is
on the github and so you can go over
here enter your payment details and this
credit card number and I should have
sped this up because it's taking too
long
and we go in and we write our you know
fake data pay with the credit card and
then we have the success so since I
don't have time to go through the entire
application I'm giving you a bird's eye
view of what that setup looks like I'm
using a thing called next which is if
you're familiar with react we have next
and react next is kind of like the view
equivalent it's got server-side
rendering routing and you're always
using dot view components for each piece
of it even if you're creating a page if
you want to create
a full page that has routing you put it
in the pages directory as a view
component there you go
so you also have components view X is
kind of like Redux if you're used to
react
I don't work with angular too much so
I'm not going to give the comparison
there and then there's also this layout
so you can have multiple layouts where
you're arranging components as well so
you can see how we're going to
communicate with stripe but we're also
going to use that server list function
and the reason why it has like a little
green thing is that we have one
dependency that's also stripe inside of
that server list function so right now
we're just going to focus on the lowest
hanging fruit which is stripe so if you
haven't set up stripe it's very easy you
set it up with just a couple clicks
convert and confirm your email and then
you go into the API tag and you can see
that it already gives you a test key
token to work with so you can test
things out so when you visit stripe
documentation it's going to expect that
you're gonna use something like Express
and it's going to ask that you need
something like an email a token and the
amount for your sample charge but we're
already executing on the server so we
don't have to use something like Express
write we're already on the server this
dog is so stoked so we don't need to use
Express first we're going to just kick
things off and we're gonna replace
obviously those X's with your stripe key
token so that module dot exports that's
that line of code that we use in Azure
that would change for other services so
here we have what we need we're going to
get the body the stripe email the stripe
token in the stripe amount and we're
going to post those and I'm going to use
Axios for all of these examples that's
kind of a common thing that people use
in these kind of applications so then
we're gonna finish you'll note that I
log a lot that's so that if anything
goes wrong I know exactly where and when
it's going wrong in the application and
now when we execute our function now
when we execute our function you can see
it is running and we have we have in
that kind of params area where we had
tacos before we have the email the token
in the
it's been completed and you can see that
everything's going through and if we go
and check in the stripe dashboard you
can see it is actually communicating
with stripe in that testing token is
working and we have some customers
coming through so we've success awesome
one other thing that we're not going to
cover here today because we don't have
time but I wrote a whole post about it
if you want to know is how to host all
of that stuff on github and add in the
dependencies and everything it's not
that many steps but if you want to go
into more detail there that's the post
to check out okay we've got one side
done let's connect things up with our
server list function and our app now
we're going to go look at our app here
and the thing that we're going to check
out is this cart dot view that we're
going to create and we're also going to
talk about that view X store because the
view X store is really where we're
keeping the shop and all the items and
everything so we have to actually make
sure that people can access that and put
things in the cart so here's our cart
are all of our products are in a big
manifest object in the view X store and
we're also storing what's in the cart as
well as the cart total so you can see
here as I add items this view Explorer
updates if you're not familiar with
these these the view dev tools again if
you're used to react react has a similar
thing so you can actually see the
components and what's being held but you
can also see what's happening in view X
as well so here's the shape of what
we're going to be building out on the
cart diffuse so first if there are items
in the cart will add our checkout
component then if the carts empty we'll
give them the ability to go back to the
main page and add items and finally if
there's success we're going to allow
people to know that it's being processed
and we're gonna add a success component
so let's look at that first code block
again if we have items in our cart we're
going to show a cart that reminds people
of what they've already purchased so we
just have some thumbnails of like what
they've been putting in the cart and how
much everything is so here's what that
will look like we've got the cart with
the thumbnails and you know just
reminding people what they have in there
and now that we're showing what's in the
cart we've got to build the actual
checkout form and here's what we'll
eventually have we have this
that's kind of embedded in the page so
if you wanted something super simple to
integrate into your site this thing the
view striped check out is just a button
that you put on your site and it creates
a straight modal totally easy like the
simplest simplest implementation you're
literally just sticking a component on
there and adding it to your dependencies
but you'll notice that we didn't do that
right it's actually skinned and it looks
like that form looks like our site so
this is legit but like let's say you
don't want people to know that they're
necessarily using stripe or you want to
also integrate PayPal or you you know
kind of want to make it look kind of
seamless then you use a thing called
stripe elements this is something that
stripe offers so we can embed it into
the page and style it like the rest of
the page and then people don't see that
you're actually using stripe under the
hood and what I suggest you use for this
I tried out a few different components
view stripe elements plus is the best
one out there so we would NPM install or
yarn add view stripe elements plus so
now we've got that cart dot view page
and we're also going to add a checkout
dot view component onto that page so
we're going to go to that view stripe
elements plus page and it gives us a few
defaults this is what the default thing
looks like it's going to expect that
you're gonna add in your stripe testing
key and on that button you see that add
click pay that pay method is really
important and we're gonna dive into the
pay method because that's where all the
magic happens when we make the Axios
call and connect it to the server list
function so here's that default stripe
elements in the script so if you're not
familiar with view we have single file
components which means we have template
script and style all in the same
component so these are all part of the
same component I'm just showing you a
small view of that so we're adding in
those imports for the stripe and then we
also have a few stripe options I've you
know kind of showed where you look at
the details for that and then you can
see in the methods that pay method so
what we'll need is to have a submitted a
complete a status and a response so we
need to track all of these things as
we're moving through the application so
we're gonna actually hold that all in
date
for the component and the props we're
gonna need from that cart page are the
total and the success so whether or not
we really need to find out how much we
have in that cart and also whether or
not it's been successful or not so
here's that pay method after we've
worked with it again we're using Axios
here so what that paint you know that
clicking that button kicks off the pay
method we have a create token promise
and we've changed the submitted to true
we're gonna use Axios to post to our
function URL and send the email the
total and the customer name and if
you're wondering where I got that URL
for the function remember when we were
in the portal in the dashboard before
and we saw that function there's this
little thing on the side that says get
function URL that's where you post to
when you're using Axios so now you can
communicate with that stripe or with
that serverless function whenever you
need to so after that's complete we'll
change the status to success clear the
cart with a mutation in view X and log
any errors so just to review that pay
method once more because it's really
important we're going to use Axios to
post the function to the function URL
track whether or not we've submitted the
form or not with this dot submitted it
sends the email token and total to the
serverless function if it's successful
it commits to the view X store mutation
clears the cart and emits to the parent
cart component that the payment was
successful and if it's it errors it
changes the status of failure logs the
error response for help with debugging
so if you're not familiar with loaders
and why they're important I did make
this loader that goes on anytime that
there's a communication with the server
because I don't know where they are I
don't know how what the latency is like
I'm not sure how long that thing is
going to take and if you want to know
more about perceived wait time these
kind of loaders can really help with
perceived wait time so what people think
they're waiting through Eli Fitch which
I think he's in the audience somewhere
he's pretending he's not here he has a
great talk about perceived performance
that everyone in the world should check
out it's called perceived perceived
performance the only kind of performance
that matters you should definitely check
out his talk so that's why we have this
loader which will make much more sense
after you check out his talk to
so in the case of failure I feel really
bad for this cat well let them know that
something didn't quite work right we're
gonna clear out anything that happens in
that pay method but not the cart and in
the case of success
good job Lennon we're gonna show a
successful animation wait for a little
bit and then reset that cart so that
they can continue shopping if they need
more materials so you can see that
little success gives you like a little
dopamine rush that something worked good
to tell your customers that something's
working for them so here's where we are
now the success is actually a component
of its own still attached to that page
and it looks like this I made a code pen
demo for you if you just want to check
out that one piece of code and we'll
create a set timeout and restart the
cart with the function on a parent which
is emitted from here so remember this
view how I told you we're going to go
through all of these steps here's what
we did so we created our cart imported
or check out component that also tracks
the successful payment if the cart was
empty we let them fill it up by going
back to the home page if the payment was
successful we showed a success component
restarted the cart on a set timeout and
cleared out what we have alright you did
it party that was not that much time to
set up an entire ecommerce site and all
of the payment methods and everything in
a real life application you'd also have
to do things like testing and stuff but
all of this stuff is available on github
in an open source repo both the function
and the shop so you can use both of them
immediately and play with them and set
up a whole ecommerce site for your needs
cool ok now let's do something really
quick that's really awesome and it will
be a lot less steps than you think it
will you'll need we're gonna create an
API for a view app so here's our
application
I made an app where I could explore
cocktails because I was like I have all
these ingredients I'm not sure what to
make I need to find something that you
know can work for all the ingredients
that I randomly have in my house before
people come over so here's a search and
a random functionality so you can just
get the ingredients from your house and
put it to use to make any cocktail but
then I was thinking about
I was like you know not everybody drinks
so to be more inclusive maybe I'll make
like an ice cream finder and you know
everybody likes ice cream and then I was
like well some people are lactose
intolerant and maybe like people have
things with sugar and maybe that's not
that inclusive so I could do a puppy
finder but you know some people like
cats really weird people know some
people like cats and some people like
are actually scared of dogs so that's
not that inclusive either so maybe we
could make a things we like finder but
that's got really I couldn't figure out
a way to build that without having like
the craziest UX ever so we're gonna use
a cocktail finder right now for today
because that's what I like but you can
imagine it's whatever thing you like in
the entire world all types of liking
things are welcome okay so we're gonna
make our service function you already
know how to do these this you guys are
such badasses you're like this is old
hat I learned how to do that five
minutes ago
okay so then we go into the portal here
we go into the before we were looking at
the function now we go into the
integrate tab so in the integrate tab we
have all of the allowed HTTP methods and
I'm just gonna select get that's all I'm
gonna allow to have here then I'm also
going to make sure that my authority and
someday I'm going to learn how to
pronounce that is anonymous so in
integrate we gave the route template a
name we gave the authorization level of
anonymous we allowed the HTTP methods of
get only and then and then with dummy
data I show you with just those three
clicks that we did we have a fully
functioning serverless api so I can go
in there immediately and say my name
toilet taco face hello taco face and it
returns so that's kind of amazing we're
gonna do some more really cool things
with this so we're gonna hook it up with
cosmos DB that's another kind of a sure
thing again you don't have to use cosmos
DB you don't have to use Azure but this
is what we're working with today so here
we've got a similar kind of app right
you kind of used to this now - you know
how next is all set up you guys are pros
and we're going to go into cosmos DB and
create a collection so here we've got
I'm going
cocktail finder the collection ID is
cocktails and the partition key is ID
and here I just I just stored three
entries so that you can kind of see it
so it's not too much to discover here
but when I'm adding all of these things
I have Moscow Mule I have the
ingredients I have the directions and
the type of glass anything with an
underscore prefixed in the key is not
something I made up that's something
that azure ads in for you after you've
created that so that's all of the things
that don't have the underscore are
things that I added so we're gonna go
back to our function to our server list
function and in integrate again we're
going to go over and page down until we
get to a char Cosmos DB and we're going
to select that so one of the bindings
that we have in the function the
function really gives us this index J s
file where you're gonna write your J s
and then it also gives us this function
JSON which allows us to add any bindings
that we need so it's going to add in
some prefilled data for us as soon as I
click that integrate but the things that
I added in were that database name which
remember it was cocktail finder the
partition the collection name which is
cocktails in the partition key which was
ID remember when I filled that all in in
a cosmos TV so we just fill that in here
this is a zoomed in view I don't know I
added this slide
so here is what HCP trigger has out of
the box but we're gonna change it
slightly so that we're adding this
context rez and we're gonna say that the
body is context bindings input document
input document is where we're going to
store all of that data that's how we're
retrieving all of the data from cosmos
dB so here if we're in the portal we can
look at the files remember I mentioned
there's function JSON and index J is a
function JSON has all of those entries
here index J s is that function that we
talked about we're gonna run that and
then as you run that you can see the
output and you can see everything's
coming out and we have all of the access
to everything that was in that cosmos dB
so here's like the world's most simple
view app we've got a you know a code pen
demo that basically says new view
for the view instance I'm gonna store in
data just info null so that I can fill
it and in created lifecycle method I'm
going and using Axios to go over to that
API that we made before and we're going
to store the response and you can see
it's really messy right now but don't
worry we're gonna do things with it that
won't make it super messy we're just
getting the data for now success
don't tell the porcupine what's gonna
happen I mean let's talk about this for
a second because it's actually really
important in a non serverless paradigm
we'd have to pick something like Express
we have to set up endpoints we have to
give your webserver secured access to
the data database server we have to
deploy all of it we created an API in
serverless with a few button clicks and
just a few modifications this is a
really big deal this is not a lot of
overhead you can create a server less
API in like five minutes
so now we have this super fun part where
we're going to use that data to output
to the page and make our things we like
app so we go over here to our pages in W
it's very similar to the code pen demo
where we've got that created lifecycle
hook we're going into we're using this
to Axios and we're getting the response
and then in app drink sink drink single
dot view we're going to output all of
the ingredients and all of the things
that we have inside of that data so
here's what we get a nice API to
traverse and create api's that are
useful for people liking things and I
like tacos
okay we have one last thing to do and
then I'll set you free for the afternoon
so for the last thing we're gonna do
we're going to make a crazy data
visualization with three J s and some
interesting data and we're going to use
server lists to add more data as we push
to github so this won't work the same
way before now we've been using HTTP
triggers but now we're going to
basically make sure that it's hat that
we're using a github webhook
and every time we pushed a master
serverless function does stuff for us
because we're lazy programmers and we
want the computer to do all the hard
work for us right we set it up once
computer does the hard work we
never have to think about it again so as
I mentioned before I'm work for
Microsoft as a developer advocate and
people often ask where my team is
speaking so I made this data
visualization where you can kind of
explore this table as you're typing it
kind of filters and stuff and you can
see where we're speaking around the
globe and we're not since we're kind of
at the end of this talk we're not gonna
go through so much detail but there's a
demo and repo with open source code I
will tweet out the link for that later
today in a CSS tricks article so I asked
so the most challenging part of creating
this was not three jeaious was not view
was not service function it was getting
all of my co-workers to write into an
Excel document where they were speaking
so eventually that happened and what I
was given was an Excel document where I
could get JSON data filled with people
where people were speaking and when in
the conference name so this is what I
started off with the pay attention to
this because we're gonna use it again in
a second and we're gonna make the
function this time we're not gonna use
the HTP trigger we're gonna use github
webhook like I mentioned before so here
we're gonna treat retrieve the geo
information for all of those things in
the original data so if you look back at
the original data notice that we have
the location is tel-aviv but we don't
have latitude and longitude and data
visualizations can't just work off of
the name of things we have to go get the
data the latitude and longitude from
Google Maps API so we're gonna go over
here and we're also of course going to
error if it doesn't go well so given an
array of entries wrapped in an iterator
we're gonna walk over each one of them
and populate the latitude and longitude
using the Google Maps API so note that
we're also going to cache some locations
as we make these API calls so we don't
have redundant calls and after this
we're going to check the cache to see if
we already looked at this location as
well that's not shown here that's in the
repo we don't have enough time to go
over every single step but so now you
can see the function at work here it's
taking all of the locations in the
github file and you can see how it's
caching each one but it's also gathering
the new ones and gonna go get the
latitude and
longitude for each one of those so in
our view X store we have that JSON file
but as soon as we pushed a master it's
going to go through all of them see if
it already has those entries and if it
doesn't it's going to update the file
like that so every time it sees one it's
like oh you have no latitude and
longitude here you go and then all of
the stuff is automatically updated and
so is everything so is our data
visualization and everything so here
remember how that table was being
filtered as we typed if you're not
familiar with view this is a super cool
thing because with a lot of other
frameworks you have to add you know
functionality in order to make that kind
of stuff work down shift for react by
Kent C dog Dodds is a really great way
to get that working and react but we
have it kind of built into view so it's
using a computed property computed
properties are really great because what
you're doing is you're storing your data
right it's kind of like get initial
state and react we have our data but
computed is another way of looking at
that data we're not actually modifying
the original data
we're simply getting a new view that
we've programmed into it and that means
we're also able to cache the logic based
on the dependencies which makes it super
performant you'll notice when you type
into one of those inputs it filters
super fast as soon as you've typed
something it just goes right away and
that's really really cool part of you
and using computed properties so here's
I'm using some reg X to make sure that I
don't care about capitalization because
people don't really care about
capitalization as they type and then I'm
basically filtering based on what they
type so here we also are making this
entire table with just some V for
directives if you're familiar with
angular directives we'll be familiar
with you it's kind of like a for loop
you know very basic and here you can see
it in action if I pick the conference
and I start to type you can see how
quickly that updates just on a couple of
keystrokes that's all the code that it
takes to make that work and I didn't add
any dependencies in computer properties
are so powerful especially if you have
to look through a lot of data
okay so you might have noticed on our
globe we need a pin for each latitude
and longitude but that's not all we're
doing we have to make it longer for
repeat instances so we'll check if the
location already exists and if not we'll
increment it otherwise we'll make new
values for them so we'll use this data
in this format to feed into our globe
visualization and yes it's not
functional but you can see here in well
maybe you can't see in the comment this
way of writing it is actually more
performant than functional if you don't
believe me we can arm-wrestle afterwards
I promise you I test it okay so in three
J s in order to work with it we're going
to mount it into a single element that's
how that works we're going to mount the
whole thing into a single Dom element
the code to create the globe is fairly
large so I'm going to use a mixin to
create the whole thing and if you're not
familiar with mix-ins they were
deprecated and react a while ago view
like some react doesn't whole thing
anyway this is not a political talk on
mounted it is important we remember we
were using created before that lifecycle
method in order to call things but we
have to use mounted here because we have
to make sure that it's mounted before we
actually call that mixin and one thing
to note here is that I also noticed that
by loading the texture previously and
then adding it into the mixin it's
slightly more performant because of the
way that those in asynchronous calls
work so just letting you know that that
is a little bit more performant way of
handling three j/s um the other really
cool thing about three Jas is you can
change its geometry super simply not
that you'd want to do this but if you
wanted to make an akasa Hedra instead of
a sphere out of the earth you could
totally do that in one line of code just
by changing it around three J s might
look a little tricky but once you get it
working has so many so many cool
abstractions and it's super powerful and
really fun to hook up with things like
view server listen view allow us to
accomplish a lot without a lot of
infrastructure it's so cool how these
technologies work so well together and
allow us to accomplish a variety
test so quickly I hope this helps you
get get you paired with server list and
view technologies really fast in the
future thank you so much
[Applause]